Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook and let's get started.
If you don't have one, make sure you go to 40daysofholiness.com and get
yours today, okay? Here's today's theme.
Today's theme is this, day four, "God planned to make
us holy before the creation of the world."
My wife and my dad both love puzzles, and a lot of times over family
Christmas, there'll be a big thousand-piece puzzle that gets dumped out and spread
all over the dining room table. You know one of the first things they do when they
get that puzzle? They dump out all the pieces, they take the box top,
and throw it away.
No they don't. You know that's not true. What do they do instead?
Here's what they do. They set it up right here
because it's the big picture. All the little pieces that
they find have to match the big picture. That's the big plan.
Today, we're going to set up a scripture and look at the big picture.
And here's the question: Who's primarily responsible for your holiness?
Whose idea was it? Ephesians 1:4, "For he," God,
"chose us in Christ before the foundation of the world,
that we should be holy and blameless in his sight."
Before the foundation of the world, God made a decision about what he was going to
do with all those who trusted in Jesus, and God
decided that we would be holy.
Before any human existed, before light was created, before there was a
planet called Earth, God had already decided
what he was going to do with those who trust in Jesus.
Now, if you're a believer in Jesus, God decreed that you
would become holy in eternity past. Okay.
First, this means that holiness was not your
idea. It was not something you sought to put into
place. I remember a story one time where we
were traveling, and we were invited, we thought, to eat
supper with the pastor of this church that we were visiting.
And so at the appointed time, there was some kind of miscommunication.
We all thought we were supposed to go over there.
We went over, knocked on the door, door opened, and they were shocked.
It was like the pastor's wife, her hair was up in curlers and all this
kind of stuff, and we were like, "Awkward." You ever had that wonder, that moment
like, "Are we really invited?" Listen, this verse means you can relax
about whether or not you were invited to the holiness party that is the Christian
family. God invited you. Second, it means
that the initiative for creating holiness in you is
not yours. The initiative always lies with God.
He started the whole thing. Now, third, I want you to notice that we will be
holy in his sight. That means you're going to be holy in
the sight of the one who is infinitely knowledgeable, infinitely
wise, and knows you perfectly. The one who is the
source of all holiness, the definition, and knows you down to the
deepest parts of your heart. He says, "You're going to be holy in my sight."
It doesn't always mean you're going to be holy in the sight of the people around
you, or that you'll even be holy in your own sight.
Your holiness, remember, is not a function of how you are thought of by
others. The source of your holiness is not
you or them either. Fourth, I want you to notice that it was decided
in eternity past. All of recorded time has
been in the light of God's eternal decision.
So you know something about your life.
Here's what we know, that all of your life, all your struggles, all
your trouble, every single second of your
existence up until now has been leading up to you being holy.
And every single second of your existence from now until you breathe
your last is going to exclusively be about
God bringing about his plan to make you holy.
Now, some of you
haven't been raised in a serious Christian home. I understand that.
Maybe you're just starting out your journey toward being a holy man or a holy
woman, and you need to know what this journey's about.
You need to know what's on the lid of the box of the puzzle, the
pieces that you've been given. You need to know that if you put all the
confusing pieces together, when you get done, when God gets done, it's
going to look like holiness.
Some of you were raised in a church or a home where holiness was taught.
I don't know how it was taught to you, but I have friends who were taught that it
was kind of a high-tension, high-stress, high-struggle
sort of thing, where God was almost
playing games with your mind. And for some of my friends, it was
almost taught to them like God was teasing them, like he was keeping from them
the one thing they really wanted. They wanted to be holy, but God's like, "Not yet.
I'm going to hide some of these pieces you need to have the holiness that you
long for."
Listen,
that's wrong. Forget all that. There has never been
one second of your life, or even of human history, that God has not
been planning to bring this holiness about in your life, in your heart.
This moves my heart because if you think he's going to hold out on you now,
you're wrong.
He is so much more motivated than you are, and he's been
working focused on this one thing for thousands
of years. So here's what I think you need to do.
I think you need to relax into God's plan to make you like Jesus.
Don't fight it. Don't draw back from it. Don't worry about it.
When you feel God weighing down on your heart, the state of your
heart,
and your need for holiness, smile.
Relax. Let God draw you toward him.
He only pulls on you in that way in order to guarantee you
that he's going to do it. He's going to make you holy like he's holy.
The greatest joy imaginable, being a partaker, a participant
in the holiness of God. The core of his being is straight
ahead of you. So you relax into the rest of this journey and know that
God is going to take you there. He planned it.
He will also put it into practice.
That's tremendously hopeful for me.
He decided before the foundation of the world
that you would be holy. So
take the time to think over this and just rejoice in that and be glad and
relax into it. Do the workbook, pray the prayers, all right?
And let the Holy Spirit just kind of soak all this into your heart as
we continue on in this 40 day of holiness journey.
God bless you. Thanks for being here today. See you tomorrow.